DOESN'T WANT THE STAFF TO GET
MAD AT HIM.
NEW LOUISIANA SENATOR JOHN
KENNEDY.
YOU HAD AN INTERESTING LINE AND
SAID BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
RELATING TO THE BORDER LIE LIKE
THEY BREATHE ABOUT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
EXPLAIN THAT TO US.
>> SEAN, I CAN'T THINK OF
A SINGLE PRESIDENTIAL
ADMINISTRATION THAT HAS BROKEN
MORE PLATES IN HIS FIRST 9
MONTHS THAN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU TALKED ABOUT IT.
AFGHANISTAN, CRIME, CRITICAL
RACE THEORY, GAS PRICES.
THE DESTRUCTION OF AMERICA'S
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE.
AND YET, OF ALL OF THE
PRESIDENT'S SCREW UPS, THERE IS
NOT A SINGLE ONE GREATER THAN
THE CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
IT IS A CRISIS.
THIS YEAR OVER 2 MILLION PEOPLE
WILL COME INTO THIS COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY AND WE DON'T HAVE THE
SLIGHTEST IDEA WHO THEY ARE.
WHY?
TO ME THERE ARE ONLY 1 OF 2
POSSIBLE EXPLANATIONS.
THE FIRST IS INCOMPETENCE.
IT MAY BE THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
PUT IN CHARGE OF HIS IMMIGRATION
POLICY A BUNCH OF PINK HAIRED
WOKERS WHO DON'T KNOW THEIR ASS
FROM THEIR ELBOW.
I USE ASS IN THE KING JAMES
BIBLE SENSE.
IT MAY BE THAT THE PRESIDENT PUT
IN CHARGE OF HIS IMMIGRATION
POLICY PEOPLE WHO SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO THINK FOR THEMSELVES
BECAUSE IT'S TOO DANGEROUS.
IT MAY THAN THE PRESIDENT IS PUT
IN CHARGE OF HIS IMMIGRATION
PEOPLE WHO SPEAK ENGLISH AND
STUPID.
NOW THE SECOND POSSIBILITY IS
THAT THIS IS ALL INTENTIONAL.
THAT THE PRESIDENT BELIEVES IN
AN OPEN BORDER POLICY AND YOU
HAVE TO WATCH WHAT PEOPLE DO AND
NOT WHAT THEY SAY.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO SAY IT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BECAUSE HE KNOWS
THAT WILL BE AS POPULAR WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AS A --
>> Sean: IN OTHER WORDS, HERE'S
THE GREATEST THING WE CAN GIVE
AS A GIFT.
AMERICAN CITIZENSHIP.
TRYING TO FORCE AMNESTY IN THE
BILL IN THE HOPES THEY WILL VOTE
FOR DEMOCRATS.
WE WILL GIVE YOU THE GREATEST
GIFT WE CAN GIVE YOU.
FREE CITIZENSHIP AND WE WON'T
HAVE A VOTE ON IT.
IS THAT A POSSIBLE MOTIVATION?
>> SURE.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW.
WE KNOW ONE THING.
THERE IS A SOLUTION.
IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
ALL THE PRESIDENT HAS TO DO IS
GO BACK TO WHAT WE WERE DOING IN
DECEMBER, THE MONTH BEFORE HE
TOOK OFFICE.
THE REMAIN IN MEXICO PROGRAM,
THE THIRD COUNTRY AGREEMENTS AND
THE BORDER WALL AND DEPORTATION.
IT WORKED THEN AND WILL WORK
NOW.
ALL HE HAS TO DO IS DO IT.
>> Sean: SENATOR YOU SPEAK FROM
A PLACE OF COMMON SENSE.
IF WE DID THAT, WE WOULD SOLVE
THE PROBLEM.
WHY DO THAT?
UNBELIEVABLE.
WE WOULD NOT ABANDON AMERICANS
BEHIND ENEMY LINES.
I WILL TAK